I'd like to talk about why women can't
seem to lose belly fat after menopause
not just going to talk about that I'm
also going to talk about what to do
about it as well so what is going on
with this menopause thing well all these
changes all stem because of this one
change that happens in the body the
ovaries go in retirement they're no
longer going to be producing or
releasing eggs now the ovary doesn't
just make eggs it also makes hor
hormones so what's going to happen as we
go through menopause is we're not going
to have the eggs we're not going to have
the the quantity of hormones but
normally what's supposed to happen is
the adrenal glands which are the backup
are supposed to kick in the adrenal
glands make all of the hormones that the
ovaries make and if the adrenal glands
are strong and stable going in the
menopause usually there's very little
symptoms if any at all so it's not
really normal noral to have hot flashes
it's not normal to have any symptoms
going through menopause unless there's a
problem with the adrenal glands but
there's a bit more to this okay so yes
it's true that estrogen drops but you're
also going to get uh a more significant
drop in progesterone so the ratios of
estrogen progesterone it actually could
make it appear that you have estrogen
dominance okay which is not really true
it's just the ratios of estrogen to
Progesterone and some women start going
on hormone PL M therapy the problem with
that is it comes with a lot of side
effects okay and complications but I'm
not going to get into that right now I
want to focus on another thing that
happens in the body that gives you a
solution to handling this entire problem
because naturally the adrenals are
supposed to take over and compensate for
the missing hormones and no this is not
a mistake in nature it all is supposed
to work very perfectly so in adrenals we
have several things going on we do have
an incre increase in cortisol that's the
stress hormone this could explain why
through menopause a woman might feel
anxiety uh excessive nervousness
difficulty sleeping uh maybe agitated
and also an overall low tolerance to
stress that has a lot to do with um this
part of the nervous system called the
autonomic nervous system and that's
really what I want to focus on in this
video so the autonomic nervous system is
basically adapting your body to the
environment your body is constantly
adapting to temperature different
environments and one part of the nervous
system called the sympathetic which is
the flut fight is increasing certain
things to adapt to the stress so let's
say for example you exercise right you
need higher pulse rate you need higher
blood pressure to compensate for the
blood flow and then right when you stop
that exercise you have another system
that kicks in called the parasympathetic
and that system is all about calming
things down and bringing things back to
normal so it's really important to have
this balance between the sympathetic and
the parasympathetic nervous system
what's interesting about menopause is
after menopause a woman is usually left
with a higher sympathetic nervous system
and a much lower parasympathetic nervous
system and if they don't know this going
into menopause they might focus more on
the estrogen problem or maybe they might
just start to exercise to really get rid
of that belly fat that they're concerned
about right and then they might find wow
it's not working it's even getting worse
in some cases and so they go to one
doctor after the next trying to figure
this this problem out so the very
important thing I want to teach you
right now is about focusing more on the
parasympathetic nervous system okay so
that's your recovery system that is the
system that influences your sleep and
your ability to recover and all the fat
burning occurs in this recovery phase if
you're too high in the sympathetic and
you don't have enough recovery then
you're you're not going to lose this
midsection no matter what you do and so
there's a lot of emphasis on exercise
okay and exercise stimulates the
sympathetic nervous system but it does
not stimulate that parasympathetic
nervous system and so what I'm going to
recommend is you shift gears and you
start to exercise your parasympathetic
it would be like taking water and
putting out a fire it calms the
sympathetic and that's going to help you
reduce cortisol it's going to help you
sleep it's going to help you have a
midsection that's flat and so how do we
train this parasympathetic nervous
system well that system is not passive
it's active in other words it is
actively working to calm you down it's
actively working to reset and bring you
back to homeostasis which is kind of
like a normal balance internally so I
guess a good uh way to explain this is
that let's say right now now you run
outside and you run up a hill really
fast okay and as you run up the hill the
sympathetic nervous system kicks in
there and it's pushing up your pulse
rate really really high you get your
blood pressure really high and you get
at the top of the hill and you're
huffing and puffing and you were at the
peak of your sympathetic nervous system
as soon as you stop okay and you do
nothing that parasympathetic kicks in
actively it's kind of like a wave that
is pushing things down it's pushing your
pulse rate down
it's an active force that is trying to
recover you okay and all you have to do
is do nothing and let it do its job and
so if you were just to wait until your
pulse rate is all the way back to normal
you would strengthen your
parasympathetic but who does that what
do people do when they work out they go
work out they get their pulse rate
really high they let it come down a
little bit they rest maybe 30 seconds if
that and they do it right back they
start exercising and right there you are
failing to exercise that recovery system
you are developing and training the
sympathetic to be really really strong
but without enough recovery and so over
time you lose the strength and capacity
to recover and so your body is ending up
just producing cortisol that's creating
more belly fat it has a hard time
sleeping so I wanted to make a big deal
about this uh video to emphasize this
one simple point that if you really
understand it you can apply it to a lot
of different things you need to rest a
lot longer between your reps and sets of
exercise as well as days of exercise so
if you to do a certain set of let's say
10 reps or a certain time period of
exercise what you'd want to do is
completely stop and wait for your pulse
rate to come all the way down okay
before you start another one of those
Cycles the same thing goes with your
entire workout through a given week week
you have to make sure you don't
overtrain you want to make sure when you
exercise you give your body a chance to
completely recover and reset and what
you're doing when you're recovering is
you are strengthening your
parasympathetic nervous system I tell
you this might sound like a very
insignificant subtle thing but in
practice it was very very successful
I've had people that I've taken them off
of working out three times a week and
put them on a workout that's just once a
week and then they finally start losing
weight now on the flip side it doesn't
mean you should only focus on the
recovery and do nothing and sleeping all
day because it takes this exercise
intensity and this stress to make it all
work out now the worst type of exercise
you could do for your belly is any type
of sustained exercise now I'm not
talking about like walking or hiking I'm
talking about jogging or running or
doing marathons or long distance
anything sustained of a moderate pulse
rate is really really bad for cortisol
and it's bad for the parasympathetic
because of this one principle of waves
everything in nature is on a wave you
have these circadian rhythms of hormones
sleep cycles your heart is on a wave it
comes up and down it contracts and
relaxes and so this is why like
high-intensity interval training is very
very good for so many things because
you're doing this short high intense
exercise with lots of rest so here are
some things to focus on start doing
short types of exercise with lots of
rest don't overtrain don't train over
soreness focus on getting more sleep and
by doing this it's automatically going
to improve your sleeping because you're
going to be improving the
parasympathetic certain types of body
work whether it's chiropractic massage
physical therapy is all going to help
omega-3 fatty acids can help as well
also the precursor to all of these
hormones it's called DHEA really good
supplement to take especially through
menopause but if if you're female I
would highly recommend you don't take a
lot of it just take what's recommended
on the bottle because if you take too
much it can start to you know increase
more testosterone which you might not
want that it's very important to go on
low carb intermitted fasting because
when you do that you automatically
reduce the sympathetic nervous system
and you increase the parasympathetics
that's some really key nutrients to
focus on magnesium choline vitamin B1
vitamin D is also important too certain
herbs can be helpful that are adaptogens
lemon bone a passion flour and
ashwagandha are really good so in
summary the parasympathetic nervous
system restores the sympathetic nervous
system which is that fight or flight
mechanism now because of the censoring
and the suppressing of the algorithms on
YouTube it's becoming more difficult to
find my content and there's a lot of
content that I cannot put on YouTube
unfortunately so to make sure you have
full access of all my information go to
drberg.com And subscribe to my
newsletter by clicking the link Down
Below in the description I will see you
on the other side if you have not seen
my stress webinar that gives you
additional techniques I put it up right
here check it
out